oh what's up brown couple I love seeing
that G's up yo Brown love how long have
y'all been together
you're not together stop wasting each
other's time dude I hate that [__] so
much who paid for the [__]
tickets if you pay for the tickets you
need to sexually harass this girl
tonight
pay for VIP nothing happening the [__]
is that
painter VIP she's talking about we
friends hey I got friends I don't even
pay for their Starbucks
I hate that [__] dude cause I've been
you I love my wife beautiful woman but I
have been you before her before I met my
life I was you then I vowed one time
I'll never do that [__] again
you're sitting there and she's she's
got PTSD think about something that
friend zone me
oh my God Akash is such a good friend
and I was like oh my God I'm dying
inside
it's a nightmare dude I had made this a
mixed paper was [__] embarrassing it
was embarrassing dude listening to
heartbroken ass songs on Windows Media
Player God damn that was a tough time
don't be me yo make a [__] move and
if she says no there's other holes out
there
oh you both the same kind of Indian what
are you where you from you're both
Punjabi
bro come on do you want to marry a
Punjabi guy yeah
not hip don't say that [__] like that yo
that was wild I guess she said that in
public we got cameras on she goes not
him though not him hey you don't wanna
know nice Punjabi guy you know most
Punjabi dues ain't [__] are there any
Punjabi guys in here look at him general
admission
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what do you do for a living that she
don't give a [__] about it you're
[Applause]
oh I'm not sick of you
I'm how sick of you
are you in med school too what who's
gonna be a better doctor what are you
going to be
anesthesia what about you that's not a
doctor what are you talking about dude
come on she don't even fix nobody hey
please help me my dad beat me why don't
you just take some Prozac shut the [__]
up man
trying to listen to you help you for an
hour get the [__] out of here I'm not
saying you're not beautiful you are
you're a very pretty girl you have a
good job but it's not a real job
this guy got it dude your parents would
be [__] thrilled bring home some
skinny ass Punjabi dude even if he does
try to hit you that [__] wouldn't hurt
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]